I was reviewing some polling data this
morning and I noticed that there is a
new poll which really shows the extent
of the cognitive dissonance and
idiocracy that we're dealing with last
week I told you that despite the fact
that Donald Trump jr. admitted to having
that Trump Tower meeting with the
Russian lawyer many Trump voters in fact
slightly more than half either don't
believe or aren't sure that it actually
happened Trump jr. admitted to it
Trump is still don't believe it we have
yet another strange poll about the
popular vote remember back in November
when Donald Trump started this entire
nonsense about the illegal voters in the
popular vote with a tweet where Donald
Trump said quote in addition to winning
the electoral college in a landslide I
won the popular vote if you deduct the
millions of people who voted illegally
that was November 27 to 2016
nice little Thanksgiving gift I guess we
would call it there was no evidence of
that period right but trumpets believe
it only 45 percent of Trump voters
believed that Don jr. had that meeting
despite the fact that he admitted to it
and now we learned that Donald Trump's
public lies have really worked because
half of Trump voters believed that it
was Donald Trump not Hillary Clinton who
won the popular vote 49% 49% of Trump
voters believe that Donald Trump won the
popular vote on November 8th of 2016
according to a new political morning
consult poll that's compared to 40% of
Trump voters who believe that Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote this is
just data this is just a fact Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote by millions
of votes 2.9 million that's a pretty
healthy popular vote margin in favor of
Hillary Clinton I often misquoted
Voltaire quote but he has a real quote
that's relevant here where he said
certainly anyone who has the power to
make you believe absurdities has the
power to make you commit in justices and
we see Trump's lies and we say what a
[ __ ] right who could possibly believe
this stuff you have
to be really clueless to even try these
lies on the general public but they work
Trump supporters many of them maybe the
right term is enough of them we could
say they believe the lives that Donald
Trump pedals regardless of what the
facts are you know of that 49% though I
wonder how many of those people
understand that officially Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote but they
don't believe this percent but buy into
this idea that three and three to five
million people voted illegally and
otherwise Trump would've won right what
percentage fall into that core category
and what percentage just don't know what
the popular vote is yeah think will
Trump won the election Klimas or is a
combination I'm sure it's a combination
and people who just don't understand the
difference between electoral and popular
vote this is why for example giving
climate science deniers fact day after
day beating them over the head with fact
it's not going to convince them to
change their minds Trump's global
warming is a hoax created by the Chinese
thing it's ridiculous to thinking people
but every single one of those assertions
works to some degree and it is scary and
disturbing how willfully misinformed
these people are if Trump had come into
office during a period of more
instability imagine what he might have
been able to get us into with his lies
and what's really frightening is how
stuff like this is not even being
considered that big of a deal because
it's arguably trivial these are people
who live in an alternate reality they're
delusional or will lie about anything
tens of millions of people who are
falling for this stuff hook line and
sinker and it illustrates a key
consequence of having these sort of
propagandist news organizations it
furthers the spread of this stuff and it
furthers the anti and the pseudo
intellectualism that we've been talking
about I really wonder if Trump
supporters understand that they are in
the minority that only you know thirty
five percentage of people or so support
him that only 20% of Americans actually
voted for him yeah they think they're in
the silent majority but maybe they're
just like it obnoxiously loud minority
and they may be it may be and it's the
same types of people that believe that
around the time of the Iraq war that
Saddam and 9/11 were connected same
people that thought Obama was at fault
for the government's response to
Hurricane Katrina despite the fact that
george w bush was president at
I'm the same people who thought Obama
was born in Kenya which is a shockingly
high number of Republicans the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership